109 Tage Krieg in Gaza gestern alleine
21 Tote israelische Soldaten durch einen
Angriff was genau ist da passiert und
warum wurde das relativ lange unter
Verschluss
gehalten also so ganz genau klar ist das
immer noch nicht und wahrscheinlich
wollte die israelische Armee auch
erstmal genau prüfen äh bevor Sie
irgendwelche Zahlen vor allem so viele
Tote das ist ja für viele Angehörige
eine Schreckensnachricht nach drauß gibt
äh es ist offenbar äh eine
Zusammentreffen unglücklicher Umstände
es waren mehrere Soldaten in mehreren
Gebäuden und haben dort mehrere
Sprengkörper
Minen wahrscheinlich eingesammelt die
sollten benutzt werden um das Haus zu
sprengen dann gab es Beschuss mit äh
raketengeschossen die man von der
Schultern abfeuern kann ein Panzer wurde
getroffen und wie dann die irgendwie
größere Explosion zustande gekommen ist
das ist immer nicht nicht ganz geklärt
aber das Haus ist eingestürzt und hat
eben alle Soldaten unter sich begraben
Micha während wir hier die Bilder sehen
die Kollegen aus der Regie spielen sie
uns möglicherweise zu Bilder von diesem
Krieg in Gaza das Material des
israelischen Militärs wenn ich das
richtig im Kopf habe eine schwere
Offensive eine unglaubliche Zerstörung
wie steht eigentlich mittlerweile die
israelische Bevölkerung zu diesem
andauernden Krieg den vielen Toten auch
auf israelischer Seite
na ja die ist gespalten allerdings
der Großteil steht nach wie vor
natürlich hinter dieser Offensive weil
es gilt eine konkrete Bedrohung die
Israel das größte leid was es jemals in
seiner staatsgeschichte erfahren hat
zugefügt hat und das ist die Hamas und
die soll zumindest militärisch
zerschlagen werden auf der anderen Seite
hat die Hamas natürlich ein
unglaubliches Druckmittel in der Hand
das ist ihre stärkste Waffe nämlich die
Geiseln und die versucht sie jederzeit
wieder zu instrumentalisieren diese
Waffe um Druck auszuüben auf die
Regierung und das gelingt natürlich auch
sehr gut weil den Angehörigen ist die
militärische Kriegsführung natürlich
egal sie wollen dass die Geisen
zurückkehren und insofern gibt es ein
sehr gespaltenes Bild hier in Israel mhm
wir haben auch Bilder gesehen von
Angehörigen die glaube ich eine
Parlamentssitzung gestört haben
vielleicht können wir auch das einmal äh
kurz zeigen und ich würde dich gerne
Fragen Michael der hamassprecher Abu
obida wurde zitiert mit dem Satz das
Schicksal vieler Geiseln aus Israel sei
mittlerweile unbekannt
höchstwahrscheinlich so drückte er sich
aus sein viele von ihnen kürzlich
getötet worden und der Rest ständig in
großer Gefahr das ist ein unglaublicher
Satz wenn man den so hört
m geprägt von riesigem Zynismus und
natürlich eine große Hoffnungslosigkeit
die daraus spricht
was löst so ein Satz in der israelischen
Öffentlichkeit
aus ja der Wahrheitsgehalt einer solchen
Äußerungen ist natürlich schwer
einzuschätzen und so wie die has bisher
imagiert agiert ist vor allem davon
auszugehen dass das wieder einmal
psychologische Kriegsführung ist um
natürlich die Angehörigen
einzuschüchtern um in den Einung zu
vermitteln eure Angehörigen Steben
schweben ständig in höchster
Lebensgefahr aber nicht wir sind schon
die iSee ist Schu wir wissen auch nicht
wie viele getötet worden sind das ist
natürlich mindestens Teil der
psychologischen Kriegsführung was
natürlich nicht daran ändert dass das
Leben der Geiseln zu jedem Zeitpunkt
extrem gefährdet ist hat man
mittlerweile eine Idee davon wo diese
Menschen sein könnten ob sie noch am
Leben sind was weiß man über das
Schicksal dieser
Leute also man hat ja vor kurzem einen
seh sehr gut ausgebauten tunnelkomplex
entdeckt das war ein Raum der gekachelt
war mit Bad allerdings richtig
vergittert wie ein Gefängnis man hat
dort Zeichnungen eines Mädchens gefunden
von dem man weiß dass es seine Zeichnung
sind weil es inzwischen freigelassen
worden ist man konnte das zuordnen und
das sind aber noch wahrscheinlich die
luxusbedingungen zu denen Geiseln
gefangen gehalten werden die Luft ist da
auch extrem schlecht und ich bin selber
mal in einem solchen gewesen vor zwei
Wochen
die Belüftung ist nicht gut die
Luftfeuchtigkeit ist extrem hoch
und der aufunterhalt ohne Tageslicht
ohne zeitorientierung ohne
Medikamente ohne ausreichendes Essen ist
wahrscheinlich sehr sehr schwierig
wahrscheinlich werden die Geiseln von
Zeit zu Zeit an andere Orte gebracht
damit man sie eben nicht aufspüren kann
also sie sind wahrscheinlich noch zu
einem großen Teil am Leben aber über
ihren Zustand kann
das heißt an dem Punkt eine sehr
verzweifelte Situation wir haben eben
Bilder von Demonstrationen in Israel
gesehen vielleicht können wir einmal
kurz die Bilder zeigen die ich eben
angesprochen habe die Störung des
Parlaments wir hören einmal kurz
[Musik]
rein ich will ihn nur Leben
zurück wenigstens einen von
drei ange sie als geiselalten
[Musik]
werden jetzt jetzt
jetzt ich verstehe ihren
Schmerz ich bin auf ihrer Seite und
fühle mit
ihnen wir werden alles tun um ihre
Kinder Brüder und Frauen wieder sicher
nach Hause zu
bringen noch einmal die Frage wie groß
ist der Druck auf Regung wie lange hält
eine Gesellschaft auch solche Bilder aus
wie groß der Druck ins besondere auf den
Regierungschef auf
Netanyahu der ist extrem hoch es geht
eben auch nicht mehr nur um seinen Kurs
bei der Verhandlung zur Freilassung der
Geisen sondern eben um seine
Kriegsführung um seine Amtsführung
insgesamt seine Umfrage Werte fallen
immer mehr ins Bodenlose und man fragt
sich wie es noch weitergehen soll aber
er versucht sich im amzuhalten und wir
haben gerade diesen einenatz ja gehört
ich weiß nicht ich habe die Bilder nicht
gesehen hier aber der sagt wir werden
alles tun natürlich wird nicht alles
getan kann auch gar nicht alles getan
werden um die Geiseln frei bekommen weil
dann müsste Israel ja im Prinzip sich
selbst aufgeben und der Heras das
komplett überlassen das heißt es werden
Versprechungen gemacht die man auch gar
nicht einhalten kann und das spüren die
Angehörigen der Geisel natürlich und der
Druck wird insgesamt auch bei der
Demonstration die ja im letzten Jahr
sowieso schon gegen die Regierung
netanyaho wegen des Angriffs auf die
Gewaltenteilung immer stattgefunden
haben diese Demonstration dieser Druck
wird immer größer mhm
klingball unsere Solidarität mit Israel
ist ungebrochen gilt der Satz nach wie
vor ich finde er gilt und man muss immer
wieder auch
einordnen warum das was wir dort an
grausamen Bildern sehen alles entstanden
ist das war der furchtbare Terrorangriff
der Hamas auf Menschen die an einem
Festival gefeiert haben auf kibozene auf
das friedliche Leben in einer Demokratie
in Israel das ist der Auslöser für alles
das was wir erleben und trotzdem Herr LZ
will ich ihn auch sagen es es zerreiß
dann ja was man an Bildern sieht auch
aus den palästinensischen Gebieten die
die humanitäre Katastrophe die zweifels
ohne da ist die hohe Zahl der Toten auch
auf der palästinensischen Seite ich
finde dass die Regierung jao auch große
Fehler macht wenn man die zwei
staatenlösung jetzt in Frage stellt wenn
man sich von der Perspektive die man für
die palästinensische Seite ja braucht
auch eines eigenen Staates quasi
verabschiedet und man merkt ja auch dass
Israel international unter Druck gerät
aber allein schon aufgrund unserer
historischen Beziehung zu Israel finde
ich haben wir eine ganz besondere Rolle
und ich halte das für richtig dass man
dort solidarisch an der Seite zu Israel
steht und ich will Ihnen auch sagen ich
halte es für richtig dass die
Bundesregierung sich so intensiv wie das
gerade passiert ich glaube es es gab
noch nie eine Regierung die sich so
intensiv in den nordostkonflikt auch
eingemischt hat mit beiden Seiten dort
geredet hat halte das für richtig dass
man dort aktiv ist und sich auch in
diesen Konflikt mit einmischt noch mal
die Frage der Solidarität mit der
palästinensischen Bevölkerung 20 SPD
Bundestagsabgeordnete an den Kanzler
einen Brief geschrieben in dem sie sagen
wir glauben dass der Preis die Hamas zu
besiegen nicht die in kaufnahme des
andauernden Leids dieser
palästinensischen Zivilbevölkerung sein
kann inzwischen äh sind auch israelische
Geisel diesen Angriffen zum Opfer
gefallen ein erneuter humanitärer
Waffenstillstand ist sofort
notwendig das heißt da dreht sich etwas
in der Debatte sind ja das sind ja die
Debatten die wir auch international
haben und wir sehen gab jetzt sogar
Gerüchte dass auch auf israelischer
Seite drüber nachgedacht wird der Hamas
einen zweimonatigen Waffenstillstand
anzubieten wenn die Geiseln sofort
entlassen werden es gab in Davos jetzt
die großen internationalen Debatten auch
und wir sehen ja dass wir als Deutsche
auch teilweise sogar in Europa isoliert
sind mit der Solidarität trotzdem noch
mal ich man muss auch immer was würde es
bedeuten
jetzt wenn Israel aufhört die Hamas zu
bekämpfen wenn Israel aufhört und die
Hamas durchatmet sich wieder bewaffnet
und weitermacht es geht um die
Vernichtung eines demokratischen Staates
das ist das erklärte Ziel der Hamas und
deswegen halte ich es für richtig dass
man die Hamas bekämpft aber dass die
Kriegsführung der Israelis auch
zunehmend in kritikgät dass es
Fragezeichen dran gibt wie diese
Kriegsführung genau ausgestaltet ist
dass es immer mehr rufe auch gibt nach
humanitären Feuerpausen das kann ich
total nachvollziehen und hoffe dass es
dort auch politische Bewegung gibt mich
du hast es vorhin angesprochen die
Situation auch in in Gaza ist
verzweifelt ich habe eine Zahl gelesen
70% aller
Gebäude zerstört oder zumindest zum Teil
zerstört ist das eine valide Zahl
das kann ich von hier aus natürlich auch
nicht überprüfen ich bin selber neulich
nur kurz im Norden von Gaza aber nur ein
paar hundert Meter hinter der Grenze
gewesen wir haben Kontakt zu unseren
Producern mit denen wir sehr lange schon
seit vielen Jahren zusammenarbeiten die
ich auch persönlich kenne aus
eigenbesuchen in Gaza die haben aber
auch keinen Zugang zum Norden die sehen
natürlich auch nicht das Kriegsgebiet in
janjunis aber ich würde mal sagen es ist
eine große Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
sehr sehr großer Teil das sind auch die
Bilder die wir jeden Tag bei uns hier
sehen ein großer Teil der Gebäude
zerstört oder in Mitleidenschaft gezogen
worden ist und was wir auch sehen
vielleicht können wir auch diese Bilder
einmal kurz einspielen Bilder von
riesigen Zeltstädten die vor allem im im
Süden entstehen was sind das für Zelte
was ist das für eine Situation wie viele
Menschen leben da ich weiß aus eigenen
besuchen es ist kalt jetzt in Israel
also auch da reden wir schnell über
Temperaturen knapp über dem Gefrierpunkt
das heißt was ist das für eine Situation
in der sich die Menschen dort
befinden ja das ist eine verheerende
Situation in der Tat es ist Moment
Winterzeit im Moment herrschen hier
Winterstürme es ist nicht nur kalt es
regnet und Stürme die an den Zelten
zerren ich kann mir kaum vorstellen dass
die alle standhalten und das sind quasi
zum Großteil selbstgebastelte Zelte
darüber wissen wir auch ein bisschen
mehr weil unsere eigenen Kollegen dort
unten in solchen Zelten zum Teil Leben
und S viele Reportagen aus diesen
Bereich auch schon gemacht haben und die
Menschen haben im Prinzip nichts und
versuchen aus nichts also mit ein paar
Stangen ich würde sagen ein besenstange
irgendetwas was man kann ein paar
plastikplan und daraus bastelt man dann
so etwas wie ein Zelt was ein wenig
Schutz bietet und das sind ganze Städte
da Leben mindestens mehrere hunderttaus
Menschen
manche sind halt immer noch auch in
ihren Häusern in janunis geraten dann
plötzlich auf einmal in die heiße
Kriegszone wie es auch heute wieder
passiert ist aber tatsächlich es sind
riesige zeltstätte angewachsen und die
Leute haben im Prinzip auch das haben
wir in Berichten zeigen können nichts zu
essen weil die Hilfslieferung nicht
ausreichen es gibt teilweise das glaubt
man nicht auf dem Markt von raffach
Gemüse zu kaufen es wird nach wie vor in
Gase angebaut aber niemand hat das Geld
das zu bezahlen weil ja niemand mehr
arbeitet und niemand mehr Lohn bezieht
also die Situation der Menschen da kann
man als nur verzweifelt bezeichnen und
bevor wir gleich auch Herrn Reineke
Fragen und die Diskussion dann auch
aufmachen Michael an Dich noch mal die
Frage es ist eben schon gefallen als
Stichwort zwei staatenlösung
ähm du sagst wenn ich dich richtig
verstehe zwei statenlösung das bleibt
eine leere Phrase eine hohle Floskel
Gelaber um es mal auf gut Deutsch zu
sagen wenn man es nicht ernsthaft mit
ein paar Dingen hinter und unterlegt
womit ja also ich sag's auch noch mal
selber es kommt einem hier
äh das was die Politiker immer hier äh
führen das große Wort von der zwei
staatenlösung das kommt einem sehr
weltfremd vor es ist letztendlich ein
Lippenbekenntnis was seit Jahren nicht
mit Inhalt gefüllt wird ein bisschen
vielleicht auch nur um das eigene
Gewissen zu entlassen weil man das
richtige fordert aber eine
Zweistaatenlösung ist weiter entfernt äh
den den je es geht eigentlich um ein
paar Punkte die man erstmal klären
müsste diese zwei statenlösung das ist
wie so ein Dach aber da drunter ist
luftleerer Raum da ist kein ersterstock
kein Erdgeschoss also etwas Tolles was
in der Luft schwebt aber der Unterbau
der Rohbau fehlt was ist der Rohbau es
geht um drei Dinge erstens
es muss erstmal der Siedlungsbau
gestoppt werden er wird nicht
zurückgedreht werden aber er muss
gestoppt werden zweitens es muss
Rechtsgleichheit spreche jetzt all vor
allem erstmal vom Westjordanland
zwischen Siedlern und Palästinensern die
dort leben hergestellt das ist nicht der
Fall
teilweise Geschehen Verbrechen oder auch
nur kleine Ungerechtigkeiten demütigen
ich war gestern wieder in der Westbank
und konnte mitbekommen wie eine
Schafsherde zufällig angeblich auf das
Gelände von Siedlungen geriet dann
mussten die äh äh Schafsherden Besitzer
150.000 Schäkel das sind fast 40.000 €
Strafe zahlen das sind die kleinen
demütigen die jeden Tag in der Westbank
passieren im Westjordanland unter dem
Schutz der Soldaten das muss aufhören
und das dritte ist natürlich die Gewalt
muss aufhören die Gewalt der Siedler
aber natürlich vor allem die Gewalt der
Palästinenser die Terroranschläge
die korrupte Regierung in
ramala führt nicht wirklich zu einem
Atmosphäre des Friedens bei aber wenn
für beide Seiten nicht dieser Unterbau
wenn nicht ein Gerüst ist von einer
tragfähigen Beziehung im Westjordanland
ja und über Gaza muss man da noch mal
sprechen wie das denn da aussehen soll
da braucht man nicht von der zwei
staatenlösung zu sprechen denn ohne
diesen Unterbau dass zumindest erstmal
Gleichheit und halbwegs Gewaltfreiheit
hergestellt wird wird es keine
Zweistaatenlösung
geben ich schaue schon die ganze Zeit zu
Herrn reinik und versuche sein nicken
und mal Kopfschütteln ein bisschen zu
interpretieren wie schauen sie da drauf
ist ein paar wichtige Punkte die Michael
da angesprochen hat vor allem die
Situation im Westjordanland diese diese
Willkür und dann hört das der arme Leute
man dann plötzlich umgerechnet 40 000 €
bezahlen soll ich hab gar keine
Vorstellung davon wie das eigentlich
gehen soll das heißt halten auch sie
das sozusagen das Gerede in dem Fall von
der zwei staatenlösung für obsolet für
etwas was eine Phrase ist na obsolet ist
es nicht denn es ist zunächst mal immer
noch die die die einzige Option die
haben um beide Völker auseinander zu
bekommen also zwei getrennte Räume zu
haben für Sie die Schwierigkeiten hat
der beveronge völlig zurecht gesagt die
die die gerade im westjorner Land wird
es ja zunehmend schwieriger dadurch dass
da zunehmend Siedlungen sind Siedlungen
sind Dörfer Städte die dort sind die von
Israelis bewohnt werden übriens keine
arabischen Israelis sondern es sind
alles nur jüdische Israelis die da
Wohnungen haben dürfen und
das muss man natürlich in irgendeiner V
Art und WE auseinanderbringen
theoretisch ist das denkbar also wo ein
Wille ist ein Weg ob man die Kraft dazu
besitzt das ist die die nächste Frage
wir haben ja jetzt bereits in der
Europäischen Union gestern am Montag
einen Plan gefunden gehabt oder eine ein
wurde ein Plan diskutiert vom Hohen
Repräsentanten Borell der zumindestens
wenn man eine
Veröffentlichung einer einer Webseite
Glauben schenkt und die mir auch glaub
ich zu sein scheint der einen anderen
Ansatz vorchlagen hat als bisher der
sagte um zu einer Zweistaatenlösung zu
bekommen jem man zunächst mal bekräftigt
muss man jetzt eine internationale
Konferenz machen zunächst ohne die
Parteien die einen gewissen Rahmen
vorgeben sollen das war bislang nier
fallall bislang sagte man immer die
Parteien müssen das Bestimmen er sagt
beide Parteien werden dazu im Augenblick
nicht in der Lage sein also muss die
internationale Gemeinschaft und er hat
eben aufgestellt aufgezählt die
Europäische Union hat die arabischen
Staaten Jordanien Ägypten und und
Saudi-Arabien genannt hat die Vereinten
Nationen genannt und die äh und die USA
dass man in diesem Rahmen versucht ein
einen neuen einen neuen Anlauf zu machen
und die Außenminister haben das im
Prinzip insofern gebilligt als der na
ostbeauftragter der EU Special
Representative also mein nach nach
Nachfolger wenn Sie so wollen sen kurmn
jetzt Gespräche führt äh um da das
umzusetzen die Schwierigkeiten die
bwerung aufgezeigt hat sind absolut da
und die Frage ist wenn dieses nicht zu
einem Erfolg führt was angesichts der
Dinge die erberung aufgezählt hat eine
durchaus Wahrscheinlichkeit ist was ist
die Alternative nicht und dann haben wir
zwei Alternativen die eine Alternative
hat man sich oder mehrere Alternativen
drei Alternativen sogar die eine
Alternative ist hat Jos B und hba
Husseini entwickelt das in eine Israelin
ein Palästinenser eine Art
Konföderation um dieses diesen
Flickenteppich irgendwie aufzuschlüsseln
vielleicht können wir einm eine Karte
kurz zuspielen um mal besser zu
verstehen worüber wir eigentlich reden
und wie sowas dann auch im Zweifel
aussehen könnte also wie hängt was
miteinander zusammen also diese Art von
Konföderation hat noch nie gegeben denn
es geht man sieht es an diesem
flickenteppig schon da müsste im Grunde
immer einzelne einzelne Teilbereiche
einer entsprechenden Autorität einmal
der israelischen der palästinensischen
zugestehen und dann eine gemeinsame
staatliche Institution haben das ist die
eine Option die andere Option ist dass
man tatsächlich einen gemeinsamen Staat
macht in dem Israelis und Palästinenser
gleichberechtigt sind das widerspreche
aber dem erklärten israelischen Staat
einen jüdischen Staat zu haben also man
sieht hier diesen Konflikt und die
dritte Option ist die die vielleicht
netanaho vorschläbt man oder von auch
den Siedlern dass man so eine Art
Autonomiegebiet hat in demem die
Palästinenser in bestimmten Teilen
gewisse Rechte haben aber aber in
Sicherheitsfragen nicht und sie sich da
in eineine Art und Weise bewegen können
also was davon realistisch ist weiß man
nicht wenn sie z.B ein Buch von AVI
prima dem früheren israelischen
Botschafter in Deutschland lesen dann
machte er darauf aufmerksam dass shon
dass er schon mal auf einen Besuch in
Südafrika begleitet hat wo der sich
voller Interesse die damals bestehende
Bantustans angeschaut hat also er zieht
daraus eine Schlussfolgerung dass Charon
das damals interessant fand ob das heute
no noch in den Köpfen der Leute
sich widerspiegelt das weiß man
natürlich nicht aber diese drei Optionen
g Südafrika ist ist ein gutes Stichwort
Südafrika verklagt ist gerade vor dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof was passiert
da gerade warum macht Südafrika das
welche Aussicht auf Erfolg hat das geht
um nicht weniger als den Vorwurf des
Völkermords ja es gibt dieser ber
Völkermord wurde ja politisch sehr
häufig in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
aufgebracht äh gerade viele arabische
Staaten aber auch andere haben es ihnen
vorgeworfen in Israel andere haben
gesagt nein das kann ja gar kein
volökermord sein
und wir haben uns also ein in einer
politischen Debatte befunden und jetzt
hat Südafrika durch diesen Antrag vor
dem Internationalen Gerichtshof in Den
Hag ein formalisiertes Verfahren
eingeleitet wo der genau definierte
Tatbestand wie der Jurist sagen würde
also die die Voraussetzung ein
Völkermord nun von den Richtern bewertet
werden das heißt man muss das irgendwie
versuchen zu belegen ja
ja man muss das genau Belen wie macht
man das also wie belegt man wie belegt
man den Völkermord also interessant wenn
man sich die
die durchliest wie die Parteien dort
pläert haben also die
die Südafrikaner die Juristen ja aber
zwei Stunden lang dort
vorgetragen haben zunächst mal die
objektiven Situationen geschildert
Völkermord ist also nicht nur die
Bestrafung sondern auch die Verhütung
von Völkermord und es ist auch nicht nur
der Mord als solche sondern auch
Vorbereitung Handlungen oder auch die
Schaffung von Lebensumstände die das
Leben von gewissen Gruppen erschwert das
haben sie also vorgetragen Besondere
aber ist immer die Absicht es muss in
einer völkermordabsicht geschehen und da
haben sie also vorgetragen und und und
auch gezeigt Äußerung des israelischen
Verteidigungsministers einige Tage nach
dem Angriff woer also sehr extrem auch
die Palästinenser als als Tiere
bezeichnet hat und dann andere
Äußerungen die dann kamen die hat er
also präsentiert und die Israelis haben
sich in doppelter Hinsicht teig die
haben gesagt ein wir verteidigen uns ja
also es kann kein Völkermord sein und
haben dann gesagt also solche Äußerungen
ja die gibt es aber das war mit der
Emotion des Augenblickes das meinen wir
nicht so ich verkürze es jetzt be sehr
stark und das Gericht muss jetzt mit
seinen 15
Richtern diese Vorträge die also
natürlich Jew zwei Stunden dauerten zu
bewerten und dann zu einer zumindestens
vorläufigen Entscheidung kommen aber ein
wichtiger Fakt der ja dabei zu
berücksichtigen ist also die Israelis
haben ja der Zivilbevölkerung mehrere
Wochen Zeit gegeben eben in den also
rauszugehen aus dem Süden
um um eben vor diesen als sie haben die
Angriffe angekündigt und die
Zivilbevölkerung konnte
fliehen und insofern ist es ja
widerspricht es ja dem Vorwurf
dass das Ziel ist die Palästinenser
auszulöschen ich meine theoretisch
könnte man den Vorwurf eher umdrehen
weil die Forderung free Palestine Frau
R bedeutet eigentlich Israel
auszulöschen also das ist aber das hier
eigentlich die Hammers also die das ist
ja sehr deutlich und Netanyahu hat es ja
auch nie behauptet dass er die
Palästinenser auslöschen wollte nein das
ist aber war einzelne Minister aber
unterhalb der Staats ich habe ja nur
immer gesagt wie die Parteien
vorgetragen haben nicht und das ist
genau etwas was was der Gerichtshof dann
zu bewerten hat vielleicht zu dem Teil
ham das ist ja schon das schwierige
hierbei denn es ist tatsächlich ein
völkerrechtliches Verfahren also nur ein
Staat kann angeklagt werden Hamas ist
kein Staat deswegen kann Hamers vor dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof in Bezug auf
die
völkermordkonvention nicht angeklagt
werden was ginge ist äh im Rahmen ich
will es nicht so kompliziert machen im
Rahmen des anderen kriegsvölkerrechtes
da würde Hammers als eine kriegsführende
Partei auch strafrechtlich
verantwortlich sein äh aber hier in
diesem speziellen Falle geht das halt
nicht das ist sozusagen die KR dieserm
ganzen Debatte okay WD gerne
abschließend Micha beunge noch eine
Frage stellen eine ganz konkrete Frage
sozusagen jenseits der der
juristischen
Perspektive ist es tatsächlich
denkbar mit einer ich sag's mal ganz
neutral palästinensischen Führung die ja
erkennbar auch einen eine große
Mitschuld trägt an diesen mittlerweile
geschätzten 25 oder mehr 1us Toten weil
sie keine gebaut hat keinen Schutz
gebaut hat für die Zivilbevölkerung
sondern aber und aber Milliarden in den
letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten an
Entwicklungsgeldern an auch
bundesdeutschen Entwicklungsgeldern
benutzt hat um Tunnel zu
bauen Wasserleitungen Wasserrohre wieder
auszubuddeln umzubauen zu Raketen und so
weiter das heißt ein ein einen riesigen
Aufwand betrieben hat um gigantische
Summen Zweck zu entfremden für ein
einziges Ziel Krieg zu führen gegen
Israel diesen Staat immer wieder
anzugreifen immer wieder zu provozieren
kann man mit einer solchen Führung
ernsthaft in irgendeiner Form etwas
gestalten was jemals eine gute
Perspektive für diese für diese arme
zivilbevölkerungeten kann sagen darf die
Entwicklungsgelder sind nicht nach Gaza
gegangen die deutschen
Entwicklungsgelder sondern das waren
letztendlich katarische Gelder die
übrigens mit willigung von von Israel
dahingegangen sind um das klarzustellen
nicht okay gut aber wir sind wir sind
uns aber dennoch eiglich in dem Befund
dass unglaublich viel Geld
zweckentfremdet worden ist das kann man
so generell einfach mal sagen Michael
wie geht deine Analyse
dazu vielleicht noch eine kleine
Ergänzung zunächst zu der Zahl der 25
000 getöteten die ist realistisch aber
genauso realistisch ist das dazu und das
wird leider sehr selten erwähnt äh in
den internationalen Medien etwa 9000
getötete hamaskämpfer gehören sonst wäre
es ja komisch dass äh gar keine Hamas
Kämpfer auf Seiten der Hamas fallen das
heißt dass die Zahl wird dadurch nicht
weniger schrecklich aber ein Drittel
mehr als ein Drittel wahrscheinlich sind
getötete hamaskämpfer das muss man
zumindest da ergänzen die Frage ist in
der Tat wie eine
äh ja de facto islamistische Diktatur
die wirklich in Jahrzehnten Gaza zu
einer Festung ausgebaut hat alle
Ressourcen verschwendet hat nur um
Israel Schaden zuzuführen vorher und
nach her äh wie die Teil eines
Friedensprozesses sein soll äh ich kann
mir das kaum vorstellen ich glaube
zumindest das ganz klar ähm auch die
Absicht der westlichen Staaten ist wir
haben es von Herrn klingball auch gerade
gehört die Bundesrepublik sieht das
jedenfalls so die Hamas muss militärisch
zerschlagen werden darf keine Kontrolle
mehr über Gaza haben auch zum Schutz der
Bevölkerung die dort lebt und die
übrigens in großen Teil nicht äh mit der
Hamas automatisch mitgeht äh es ist
Moment so ein gewisser Trennungsprozess
die Hamas die in Gaza ist und die
hamasführer die woanders sind und die
Hamas darf man nicht vergessen ist auch
im Westjordanland stark ich kann nicht
sagen ob man ganz darum herumkommt die
Hamas aus einem größeren Friedensprozess
auszuschließen eines ist jedenfalls klar
es muss klar gemacht werden dass mit
dem Ziel Israel zu zerstören und
dauerhaft äh Schaden zuzuführen dass
solche Menschen kein Gesprächspartner
sein können und dass da die Hamas einen
anderen Kurs als politische Partei
einschlagen muss ob sie das kann ob sie
die Kraft dazu hat das wage ich zu
bezweifeln michael war sicher nicht das
letzte Mal dass wir uns darüber
unterhalten haben ich danke Dir sehr und
pass auf Dich auf danke dir darf ich
noch einen Satz sagen ja gerne die
Europäische Union in diesem zehn punktel
hat ganz bewusst gesagt Sie wollen der
der palestinänische Verhandlungspartner
soll nicht die Hamas sein sondern die
palätinische Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde und die PLO und mir ist
eine Sache wichtig die Palästinenser
sind nicht die
Hamas das ist mir ganz wichtig ich war
ich war selbst Anfang letzten Jahres in
den palästinensischen Autonomiegebieten
warenramala sag auch deswegen ich will
die zwei staatenlösung nicht als
selbstverständlich in den Raum stellen
aber ich halte es auch nicht für leheres
Gerede das will ich an der Stelle auch
klar sagen ich bin zurückgekommen aus
den palästinensischen Autonomiegebieten
ich habe das Verhalten der Siedler dort
gesehen und mir war sehr bewusst dass
das in sehr weite Ferne gerückt ist
diese zwei staatenlösung und der 7
oktober hat es in noch weitere Ferne
gerückt aber den
Palästinensern die nicht die Hamas sind
und die die Hamas nicht unterstützen die
Perspektive auf ein eigenes Land zu
nehmen das macht richtig viel in der
Region kaputt und deswegen glaube ich
müssen wir ob es mit der Europäischen
Union ob es mit den arabischen Ländern
ist dort gibt's ja auch viele die diesen
Flächenbrand verhindern wollen auch noch
mal hier ist die amerikanische Regierung
die Bundesregierung die Europäische
Union mit vielen im Gespräch aber sich
dort Gedanken zu machen wie man diese
Perspektive für die zwei Staaten
Lösungen schaffen kann das halte ich
nicht für leeres Gerede sondern
wahrscheinlich für eine der wenigen
Optionen wie es gelingen kann irgendwann
wieder in friedliche Bahn zu kommen ich
weiß dass es alles wahnsinnig
anstrengend ist aber die Frage ist dann
immer in der Tat was wäre die
Alternative und die Alternative zu einer
Zweistaatenlösung die beispielsweise
darauf setzt dass eine Seite sich
durchsetzt in diesem Krieg die halte ich
für ausgeschlossen und deswegen lohnt
sich sagen alles was an diplomatischen
Initiativen unternommen wird um die zwei
staatenlösung zu erreichen also
720 km Tunnelsystem ne ich dieser Tag in
der New York Times gelesen das Berliner
u-bahnetz hat wie 100 140 150 mal klar
zuumachchen welche Dimension das hat und
wie da Gelder über Jahrzehnte offenbar
Zweck entfremdet worden sind klar aber
wir befinden uns jetzt glaube ich zum
ersten Mal vielleicht in einer Phase wo
auch in Israel und bei den
Palästinensern noch malh sehr deutlich
wird dass der Preis für diesen Konflikt
extrem hoch ist und zwar auf beiden
Seiten und wenn wir Glück haben
entwickelt sich daraus tatsächlich eine
ein neues Verständnis dafür dass man
eben eine Friedenslösung braucht wir
haben zum ersten Mal auch die arabischen
Staaten dabei was früher auch nicht der
Fall war die Saudis z.B die Saudis dabei
nicht nicht nur also ich glaube man kann
schon eine Chance daraus sehen und ich
finde genau diese diesen europäischen
Plan durchaus aus gelungen weil er
tatsächlich jetzt einmal die die beiden
Konfliktparteien die natürlich extrem
emotionalisiert sind aus nachfolgzibaren
Gründen erstmal herausnimmt man kennt ja
im Grunde genommen etwa den die das
entergeb dass man weiß ungefähr wie es
aussehen kann n der Weg dahin ist
besonders schwierig also ich glaube ich
werde jetzt gar nicht so pessimistisch
aber es wird natürlich schwierig sein
und die die Spoiler wie man so schön
sagt also diejenigen die das verhindern
wollen sind natürlich an jeder
Straßenecke nicht davon muss man
ausgehen